>>> FLORIDA'S GOVERNOR RON
DeSANTIS SUSPENDED TAMPA'S TOP
ELECTED PROSECUTOR.
THE GOVERNOR SAYS HE REMOVED THE
STATE ATTORNEY, ANDREW WARREN,
FOR, QUOTE, NEGLECT OF DUTY AND
INCOMPETENT, UNQUOTE.
THAT NEGLECT APPEARS TO BE A
LETTER THAT WARREN SIGNED ALONG
WITH 83 PROSECUTORS NATIONWIDE
PLEDGING NOT TO PROSECUTE ANYONE
WHO SEEKS, PROVIDES, OR SUPPORTS
AN ABORTION.
>> AND I DON'T THINK THE PEOPLE
OF HILLSBORO COUNTY WANT TO HAVE
AN AGENDA THAT IS BASICALLY
WOKE, WHERE YOU'RE DECIDING THAT
YOUR VIEW OF SOCIAL JUSTICE
MEANS CERTAIN LAWS SHOULDN'T BE
ENFORCED.
>> I'M JOINED NOW BY THE MAN
ELECTED TWICE BY THE PEOPLE OF
THE COUNTY JUST NAMED BY THAT
GOVERNOR, HILLSBORO COUNTY,
ANDREW WARREN.
GOOD TO SEE YOU, ANDREW,
ALTHOUGH I'M CERTAIN THAT YOU
HAVE QUITE THE REACTION TO WHAT
HAS HAPPENED TODAY.
I WANT TO JUST ASK THIS
QUESTION, THOUGH, BECAUSE I
THINK THAT PEOPLE MIGHT NOT
FULLY UNDERSTAND WHAT'S HAPPENED
TODAY.
WERE YOU PRESENTED WITH A CASE
WHERE YOU WERE TOLD OR HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROSECUTE
SOMEBODY WHO WAS SEEKING,
PROVIDING, OR SOME WAY HELPING
TO ACQUIRE AN ABORTION AND YOU
REFUSED TO PROSECUTE?
OR THIS WAS A HYPOTHETICAL THAT
YOU WERE RELEASED ON?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, I HAVE TO ASK
THE GOVERNOR.
THAT CERTAINLY WASN'T PRESENTED
WITH ANY CASE.
AND THIS JUST SHOWS HOW FLAGRANT
THIS OVERREACH IS.
THIS IS A BLATANT VIOLATION OF
THE MOST FUNDAMENTAL PRINCIPLES
IN OUR DEMOCRACY THAT THE PEOPLE
GET TO ELECT THEIR LEADERS.
IT'S HOW DEMOCRACY WORKS.
EVEN MY 8-YEAR-OLD UNDERSTANDS
THAT.
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, YOU AND I ARE
BOTH PROSECUTORS, AND I
CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND THE IDEA OF
PROSECUTORIAL DISCRETION.
AND THERE ARE CHOICES MADE ALL
OF THE TIME ABOUT WHETHER TO
PURSUE CASES, WHETHER TO NOT
PURSUE CASES.
THIS IS REALLY PART OF THE JOB
AND PART OF, I ASSUME, WHY ONE
WOULD ELECT SOMEONE TO BE A
PROSECUTOR AS WELL.
SO, IN THAT INSTANCE, BASED ON
THAT, WHY WOULD THIS BE A
DERELICTION OR A NEGLECT OF DUTY
FOR YOU NOT TO -- OR FOR YOU TO
DECIDE HOW TO WIELD YOUR
DISCRETION?
>> IT'S NOT.
I MEAN, THAT'S THE BOTTOM LINE.
IT'S NOT A DERELICTION OF DUTY.
IN FACT, IT'S NOT EVEN TALKING
ABOUT THINGS I'VE DONE IN
OFFICE.
IT'S TALKING ABOUT THINGS I MAY
DO IN THE FUTURE FOR A LAW THAT
DOESN'T EVEN EXIST YET.
I MEAN, THIS IS OUT OF, LIKE,
1984 OR WELL YAN THOUGHT POLICE.
I SAID IF A LAW WAS PASSED LIKE
THIS, I WOULD MAKE SURE I USE MY
RESOURCES TO KEEP OUR
NEIGHBORHOODS SAFE, PROMOTE
JUSTICE, AND FAIRNESS.
THE GOVERNOR IS JUST GRASPING AT
STRAWS HERE.
HE'S NOT CARING ABOUT WHAT'S
BEST FOR THE PEOPLE OF
HILLSBORO.
HE'S CARING ABOUT HIS
PRESIDENTIAL AMBITIONS.
>> BASED ON THE CAVEAT YOU JUST
GAVE, YOU DID SIGN A LETTER THAT
ESSENTIALLY SAID, LOOK, I'M NOT
GOING TO PROSECUTE A CASE LIKE
THIS WITHOUT HAVING A CASE
BEFORE YOU, WITHOUT HAVING A
SPECIFIC FACT PATTERN TO TALK
ABOUT.
YOU SAID IF THAT LAW WAS PASSED,
YOU WOULD NOT THEN DO SOMETHING
TO PROSECUTE.
WHY WOULD THAT BE EXCUSABLE IF A
PROSECUTOR'S JOB WAS TO ENFORCE
THE LAWS AS WRITTEN?
>> I'M GLAD YOU ASKED THAT.
IT'S A GREAT QUESTION.
BECAUSE I PUT MY HAND ON THE
BIBLE AND I SWORE TO UPHOLD THE
U.S. AND THE STATE
CONSTITUTIONS.
AND AT THE TIME I SIGNED THAT,
ROE V. WADE WAS STILL THE LAW OF
THE LAND UNDER THE U.S.
CONSTITUTION.
AND THE FLORIDA CONSTITUTION HAS
AN EXPRESS RIGHT TO PRIVACY.
THE LAW THAT THE GOVERNOR IS MAD
AT ME FOR SAYING I WON'T
ENFORCE -- WHICH, BY THE WAY, I
SAID I WOULD LOOK AT ON A
CASE-BY-CASE BASIS -- IS A LAW
THAT'S UNCONSTITUTIONAL, THAT'S
ALREADY BEEN HELD
UNCONSTITUTIONAL FOR THE FIRST
COURT TO LOOK AT IT.
>> I WANT TO PLAY WHAT GOVERNOR
DeSANTIS HAD TO SAY BECAUSE HE
TOUCHED ON THE NOTION OF NOT
LOOKING AT A CASE-BY-CASE BASIS.
HERE HE IS.
>> WE ARE GOING TO MAKE SURE
THAT OUR LAWS ARE ENFORCED AND
THAT NO INDIVIDUAL PROSECUTOR
PUTS HIMSELF ABOVE THE LAW.
YES, YOU CAN EXERCISE DISCRETION
AND INDIVIDUAL CASE, BUT THAT
DISCRETION HAS TO BE
INDIVIDUALIZED AND CASE
SPECIFIC.
YOU CAN'T JUST SAY YOU'RE NOT
GOING TO DO CERTAIN OFFENSES.
>> SO, THAT'S NOT WHAT YOU WERE
DOING YOU'RE SAYING BY SIGNING
THAT LETTER WITH ROE V. WADE,
YOU WERE REFERENCING.
MENT AND YOU DO STILL INTEND,
SHOULD YOU BE IN THAT POSITION,
TO ACTUALLY LOOK AT A
CASE-BY-CASE BASIS.
IS THAT RIGHT?
>> YES.
AND I'VE SAID THIS FROM THE
BEGINNING WHEN WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT THE ABORTION LAW, THAT
EVEN THOUGH THERE'S A RIGHT TO
PRIVACY IN FLORIDA AND EVEN
THOUGH THE LAW THAT THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED IS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL, IF WE PUT
THOSE THINGS ASIDE FOR A MOMENT,
IF A CASE COMES TO ME, WE
EXERCISE DISCRETION UNDER THE
NEW LAW AS WE WOULD UNDER THE
OLD LAW.
THERE'S A DIG DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
A TAMPA GENERAL HOSPITAL DOCTOR
PROVIDED ABORTION AT 24 WEEKS
VERSUS A BACK ALLEY ABORTION AT
37 WEEKS.
AND ANY GOOD PROSECUTOR WHO'S
FOLLOWING THE LAW OR LOOKING AT
THE FACTS OF THE CASE AND THE
LAW BEFORE MAKING A CHARGING
DECISION.
AGAIN, THE GOVERNOR IS JUST
UPSET BECAUSE I'M NOT KOWTOWING
TO HIS AJEN AT THAT.
I'M THE ONE UPHOLDING THE LAW
HERE.
THE LAW IS CLEAR IN FLORIDA.
A 15-WEEK BAN IS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL, AND I SAID I'M
NOT GOING TO ENFORCE IT.
>> I KNOW THAT YOU HAVE BEEN
SUSPENDED.
WHAT IS YOUR THOUGHT ON THE AN
TIS PAUGS OF POSSIBLY BEING
REINSTATED BY THE FLORIDA STATE
SENATE.
THEY DON'T ACTUALLY COME BACK
INTO SESSION, I THINK, UNTIL
MARCH.
DO YOU INTEND TO GO BACK TO WORK
TOMORROW NONETHELESS?
>> I'M GOING TO CONTINUE DOING
WHAT THE HILLSBORO COUNTY
CITIZENS ELECTED ME TO DO, WHICH
IS KEEP OUR NEIGHBORHOODS SAFE
AND PROMOTE FAIRNESS AND JUSTICE
AND A RULE OF LAW.
I'VE DONE THAT EVERY DAY FOR THE
PAST FIVE AND A HALF YEARS AND
I'M NOT GOING TO STOP NOW.
THE REALITY IS THE GOVERNOR CAN
SIGN SOME ORDER IN HIS PEN OR
HIS CRAYON, AND IT DOESN'T STOP
WHAT THE VOTERS VOTED FOR ME TO
DO.
>> IT WILL BE AN INTERESTING
MORNING TOMORROW IN YOUR OFFICE.
THANK YOU FOR BEING PART OF THE
SHOW.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
>>> LOOK, THE CONTEXT IS AS
CLEAR AS THE LATEST REPUBLICAN
POLLING, BY THE WAY.
GOVERNOR DeSANTIS IS THE ONLY
REPUBLICAN BESIDES DONALD TRUMP
WITH DOUBLE DIGIT SUPPORT FOR
THE 2024 NOMINATION.
LOOK AT THAT.
IT'S AN INVERSE, 43, 34 -- LOOK.
I CAN DO MATH, EVERYBODY.
I CALLED IT AN INVERSE.
WHY IS EVERYBODY LAUGHING?
OF COURSE I CAN DO MATH.
SCOTT JENNINGS, ABBEY.
I GET IT.
WE'RE LAWYERS.
WE BILL PEOPLE.
WE DON'T DO THE MATH.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THE IDEA,
GOVERNOR DeSANTIS HAS SOMEBODY
SUSPENDED, BASICALLY ESCORTED
OUT OF THE BUILDING, BECAUSE HE
WON'T EVENTUALLY LOOK AT A CASE
IN HIS MIND CASE-BY-CASE AND
DOESN'T WANT TO -- DOESN'T
INTEND TO FOLLOW WHAT THE
SUPREME COURT SAYS HE'S SUPPOSED
TO FOLLOW OR NOT FOLLOW.
WHAT'S YOUR THOUGHT?
>> TWO TAKE AWAYS, LAURA.
NUMBER ONE, THAT GOVERNOR
DeSANTIS USED THE WORD "WOKE" IN
THAT SPEECH VERY INTENTIONALLY.
IF THERE'S A 2024 REPUBLICAN
PRIMARY, BEING TOUGH ON WOKENESS
WILL BE JUST AS IMPORTANT AS
BEING TOUGH ON CRIME OR BEING
TOUGH ON CHINA.
I THINK A LOT OF THE THINGS
GOVERNOR DeSANTIS HAS TO DO
GOING FORWARD HAVE TO BE LOOKED
AT THROUGH THAT PRISM.
ALL MY LIFE, MOST OF MY LIFE,
REPUBLICANS HAVE SAID, THE
GOVERNMENT THAT GOVERNS BEST IS
THE GOVERNMENT THAT'S CLOSEST TO
THE PEOPLE.
THAT WOULD BE THE VOTERS OF
HILLSBORO PEOPLE AND THEIR
DISTRICT ATTORNEY.
IF THEY DON'T LIKE HIM, THEY
THINK HE'S TOO WOKE, THEY CAN
VOTE HIM OUT IN 2024.
BUT APPARENTLY NOW THE IDEA IS
IT SHOULD COME FROM TALLAHASSEE
OR WASHINGTON.
>> THE UMBRELLA OF WOKENESS IS
GETTING BIGGER AND BIGGER AND
BIGGER.
WOKENESS SEEMS TO BE ANYTHING
THAT IS NOT WHAT THE GOVERNOR
WANTS, RIGHT?
THAT'S NOT ACTUALLY CRITERIA FOR
WOKENESS, IS IT?
SCOTT JENNINGS, HOW DO YOU
DEFINE WOKE?
>> WELL, I'LL JUST GIVE YOU A
MACRO VIEW.
THERE ARE REPUBLICANS ALL OVER
THIS COUNTRY WHO ARE QUITE
CONCERNED ABOUT A GROWING NUMBER
OF LIBERAL PROSECUTORS WHO SEEM
TO BE MORE INTERESTED IN THEIR
OWN PERSONAL IDEOLOGICAL AGENDA
THAN THEY ARE IN PROSECUTING THE
LAWS.
HE'S NOT THE ONLY PROSECUTOR
WHO'S ELECTED AROUND THE COUNTRY
WHO HAS SAID, I WON'T DO CERTAIN
KINDS OF PROSECUTIONS.
DeSANTIS MADE AN AGGRESSIVE MOVE
HERE AND OF COURSE EVERYBODY'S
GOING TO FREAK OUT ABOUT IT.
BUT THIS IS JUST TO GIVE YOU --
WE'RE ALL POLITICAL ANALYSIS.
THIS IS HIS INSTINCT THAT HAS
PUT HIM UP WHERE WE SHOWED HIM
ON THE POLLING, FINDING A WAY TO
PROVOKE A REACTION THAT GETS HIM
THE ENEMIES THAT YOU NEED A
POTENTIAL REPUBLICAN PRIMARY TO
RISE.
AND HE'S DONE IT TIME AND AGAIN.
HE DID IT WITH DISNEY.
YOU KNOW, HE HAS DONE IT OVER
AND OVER AGAIN.
SO, ONE OF THE REASONS HE IS
SITTING AT THE TOP OF THE
NON-TRUMP HEAP IS BECAUSE HE
DOES HAVE AN INSTINCT TO
PERCEIVE THESE OPPORTUNITIES AND
THEN TO AGGRESSIVELY ACT ON
THEM, WHICH IS SOMETHING
REPUBLICAN VOTERS ARE LOOKING
FOR OUT OF THEIR NATIONAL
CANDIDATES.
>> WITH THE OVERTURNING OF ROE,
WE KNEW THAT NIGHT THAT WE WERE
GOING TO SEE GOVERNORS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY IN THESE RED STATES
JUST TRIPPING OVER THEMSELVES
TRYING TO GET FURTHER TO THE
RIGHT OF THE NEXT ONE BECAUSE
THEY WANT HEADLINES AND THEY
WANT TO MAKE A NAME FOR
THEMSELVES.
BUT WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
HERE TOO, AND I HOPE WE DON'T
GET LOST ON THIS, HE'S UPSET
THAT AN ATTORNEY MIGHT NOT
PROSECUTE OR CRIMINALIZE A
DOCTOR OR A WOMAN SEEKING AN
ABORTION.
I MEAN, THAT IS WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HERE.
THAT IS WHERE WE ARE RIGHT NOW
IN THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
THE STATE OF FLORIDA, RIGHT?
I MEAN, IT IS HORRIFYING THAT
WE'RE EVEN HAVING THIS
DISCUSSION, THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT CRIMINALIZING ABORTION.
BUT THAT IS WHERE WE'RE AT RIGHT
NOW.
AND HE MIGHT WIN A REPUBLICAN
PRIMARY.
BUT HE BETTER BE PAYING
ATTENTION TO WHAT JUST HAPPENED
IN KANSAS.